well seeing how last year everyone
seemed to enjoy seeing me get tortured
with the Disney sequels this year I'm
gonna do something kind of similar at
least I think it's similar in that I
haven't seen any of the subject matter
I'm gonna review this month I'm talking
about the Disney Channel original movies
now seeing how they started in 1997 I'm
not gonna lie they were a little past my
time so I didn't grow up with any of
these why are they worth talking about
them well because the Disney Channel
Original Movies got so popular that
almost helped define a whole generation
okay not too fine but it was a big part
of it it was too many kids would say
Ninja Turtles was to me or he-man or
transformers or any of these other silly
things that a lot of people my
generation grew up with yeah they were
ridiculous but they also left an impact
for some reason well all through the
month of December I'm gonna take a look
at these films and tried to figure out
why they were so popular if they deserve
to be so popular and if they hold up as
an adult or were they only meant for
kids and even if so were they really any
good for kids now if you take a look you
quickly realize there are a ton of these
movies that go way beyond how many days
there are in December so I'm only gonna
try and do the most popular ones and if
there were ever any sequels to did they
deserve the attention the popularity
well there's only one way to find out I
have no idea if I'm in for something
great or something terrible or both I'm
curious to see what a generation under
me grew up with and it actually holds up
at all some of these are even movies
based on shows I'll get an idea what
kind of shows kids were watching - am i
in for a wild adventure or nothing but
pain there's only one way to find out
this is Disney summer the Disney Channel
original movies let's do this
so the very first filmed ever premiere
was in 1997 called under wraps I'll
admit I don't remember people really
talking about this but it is the very
first one so I think it figures to talk
about now from the story under wraps
ounds like the most phoned in Disney
Channel movie you can imagine three
quirky friends get together and break
into an old creepy house they discover a
mummy's tomb and inside it a mummy and
the mummy comes alive and starts running
through suburbia not knowing where to go
or what to do wouldn't you know it a
little friendship starts up but some
evil mobsters want them for themselves
and yet this sounds really friggin
stupid but surprisingly for such a lame
and overdone setup this can really be
funny creative imaginative and even have
kind of a dark sense of humor yeah no
joke don't believe me just look at how
it opens a family is arguing around a
dinner table the little boy calls his
sister a cow every starts also to life
Lea mean-spirited the father goes to do
the dishes but then a knife falls in the
garbage disposal spinning around when a
monster breaks through the window grabs
his head and stabs it on the spinning
knife in the garbage disposal holy shit
I can't believe this is a Disney Channel
rich of a movie starting off this way
now of course it goes the direction you
think it's going it's not really
happening it's a movie they're watching
but even in the movie the whole entire
theater goes red like the gore happens
they're just not showing it and that's a
really creative way to kill somebody
this film starts off with already a
really original way of killing somebody
off but it doesn't just stop there the
kids in this movie are super cynical the
lines they say to each other are almost
like Simpson lines even though they
can't swear or do anything that wrong
there is kind of this edge to them that
reminds me a little bit of Monster Squad
it's hard to explain is kinda like this
natural mean-spiritedness that most kids
have at that age but for some reason
aren't really shown on screen that much
kids do throw insults at each other and
they tried to see if they can one-up one
another they talked about sleeping in
the nude they want to go inside this
house where somebody died just because
they can they discover later that
there's a key to get into the house and
when they asked why they didn't use it
they're like what's the fun in that
breaking is much more
cool it's that bizarre kind of kid logic
I strangely enough kind of remember at
that age this is line where this one boy
asked what to sell him to Semien and the
girl says it means no chicks he says he
could never do that and she says trust
me you'll get used to it okay it's not
shocking but it's just that little extra
that separates it from a generic Disney
film and on top of that all the
characters are strange like really weird
odd people there's a guy who owns the
weirdest bookstore that's covered in
skulls and gore and he answers the door
by pretending he has a knife stabbed in
his back and he falls to the ground
how would that keep any customers that
would scare everybody away but that's
more important to him than actually
selling anything even the characters at
the fast-food joints are kind of weird
and odd they all have distinct
characters and allow them just focus on
hurting this poor mummy every other
second he's either being smacked or
pulled or even burned look at this his
nipples are on fire and this is that a
hospital - everything is just out to
hurt those poor guy speaking of which
this is the same guy who is from coach
and gargoyles and he actually has two
roles than this he plays the mummy who
sadly doesn't have much talking or
expression but he still does okay and
they also place the guy who's dating the
main kid's mom he doesn't like him very
much despite him being very nice and
yeah they're kind of doing like a
Captain Hook thing aren't they were both
the father or father to be and
supernatural character kind of represent
that fear of what's coming forward but
then you see he gets used to the monster
as he'll get used to the dead and yeah
you know what this actually kind of
works it's been done but I think a lot
of the stuff in this movies been done
but they kind of playfully acknowledge
it even when it's really stupid at the
end where they have to fight off the
phony gangsters how do they do it they
pretend like their eyes are gushing out
of their heads and then they knock the
person out and tie them up with
intestines I love this kind of stuff you
would never see this in a Disney movie
this kind of just barely g-rated humour
tickles me in just the right way it's
not overly dark and aggressive to a
point where it becomes awkward but it's
just enough the downside is the second
half does slowed down a little bit and
some of the laughs go a little quiet but
I thought the whole thing was gonna be
like that for
good I don't know two-thirds of the
movie I was surprisingly kind of
enjoying it okay not loving it but there
was some lass here in there
I don't know I'm not gonna act like this
is anything great but for a little
Disney Channel movie I thought it
actually had more to it than it needed
if you're looking for that little kid
Halloween movie that goes a little
further than it needs to with some
memorable characters weird scenes and
surprisingly funny lines I say this is a
three we're checking out in the same way
a kind of self-aware b-movie is worth
checking out take a look for yourself
and see if it's worth getting wrapped up
in
you